Stars, galaxy, in astral seas abound, on cosmic paths we'll trace.
Man, we're wanked, is such a wondrous thing.
Behind, doofs of rumsey, come take your place.
We're leaving soon for-
Explored so far and still nothing to report.
It's like it's the same for all the other spacecraft combing this sector.
You suppose the Cassapians are making less trouble since learning their lesson on the green planet?
Don't bet on it.
The Cassapians are real bad.
I hate thinking about them.
As far as I'm concerned, you're 100% right.
You know, it's kind of nice having you as a co-pilot.
What's a nice girl like you doing as a space pilot?
Well, the flying part is easy.
Just learn a little astronomy and some math, and the computer does all the rest.
A basically inaccurate remark.
Computers have memory banks containing the greater part of man's knowledge, true.
However, in space, the unexpected is what we anticipate,
and no machine replaces the human capacity to react.
Sounds just like the professor.
But you still want to go on studying geology.
Yes, I want to go on.
Geology concerns tangible objects, things you can touch.
I guess it sort of balances out all of the other confusing abstractions no one really understands.
They scare me a little.
Well, in the meantime, co-pilot, how about plotting a course toward planet number 4 on our circuit?
Listed in Galactic Group 7052, identification number NGC18.
Oh, do we have to go there?
Sure we do. Why shouldn't we?
I don't know, but we shouldn't. It's dangerous. I can't say why, but I've got a hunch.
Sorry, Psyche, but we have orders, and we'd better obey them.
Okay, let's go.
Set course for open constellation 7052.
Straight ascent, 14 minutes, 30 seconds.
Declination, north, 6 degrees.
Co-pilot, plot our flight course.
Yes, Commander.
Star cluster 7052, co-pilot Psyche is right.
It is better to avoid young stars like these.
It is uncertain exactly how they have evolved.
There are many unknown variables.
It could be very...
Young stars are forming a stable cluster.
If they move in the same direction and at the same speed, no problem.
But if one falls into the gravitational field of another, it can unleash immense energy.
Be very careful.
When matter is violently drawn back upon itself, a billion times more energy is re-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e!
I can't stir it.
The ship's out of control.
No response!
This is Dragonfly.
We're caught in a giant gravitational storm.
Spaceship damaged.
Control no longer functioning.
Being pulled into the gravitational field of a planet on Star Cluster 7052.
Our position is, regardless of what Metro says,
I hope our computer is programmed to handle things like this.
No, no, no, no problem.
We've had it.
Person of my importance.
Well, that's better.
Now then, just what is the situation?
No, my knee joints.
Why couldn't I have been made a newer model?
My, my, human beings are such fragile creatures.
Well, as usual, I know what to do.
As you say, hang in there, Peter.
Ah, Psyche, you all right?
Oh, there she's coming, too.
You scared me, you know that?
Going to function?
No, it's useless. Nothing's working on the ship.
If we could repair this crate, you reckon it'd take how long?
Initial estimates, three months in a spaceport dock with specialized technicians.
And that is the strict minimum.
The radio's out, too.
And our computer's a nice pile of junk.
We're lucky you made it.
We're lucky the computer worked okay, or we wouldn't be here now.
Well, from now on, Psyche, when you got a hunch, I'll pay attention.
You were absolutely right.
Yeah, okay. But what do we do now?
Logically, correct procedure is wait here until Omega locates us and sends help.
He's right. We wait.
And hope that Master Control on Omega heard our signal,
and that they can locate this planet from all the rest in this star sector.
So for the time being, we might as well be as comfortable as possible.
I wouldn't mind if the air conditioning still worked.
Like a furnace.
How lucky can you get we land on a planet where the sun never sets?
Crazy, erratic cycle.
The heat's terrific.
I think Medro should check it out and report back.
Always when drudgery's to be done.
Guess who?
We shall now furnish report requested. We are at present located in the northern sector of this miserable planet in full exposure to the rays of its circumpolar sun.
Blazing star, if I may so name it, describes one elliptical orbit every 38 hours.
In short, it never sets, is soon to begin approach phase of cycle, and there's no means of protection.
So if I'm reading you right, what you're saying is we'd cook if we went out there.
And we'll roast if we stay in before the red sun gets any closer. Why don't we leave?
In the Southern Hemisphere, it's cooler. We could try to get there.
Leave the ship?
Yes, but then how would they ever find us, Metro?
If they come in close enough, they'll be able to follow our path with InfraVision.
And their radio receivers can pick up voices at 10,000 miles.
What do you think, Metro? Is this planet inhabited?
Not possess sufficient data to reply.
According to reports issued by the Andromedans, the governing power, one planet in 200, is inhabited.
Better begin to climb. Get on a mountaintop.
If we can get a fix on three stars, we'll be able to determine our own position.
With our silk metallic spacesuits on, we'll have some protection against the heat.
You're right. It's the only way.
Well, it's now or never. We'll have 15 hours to find a shelter from the sun.
Otherwise, we're going to be roasted chickens, trusting old Metro's calculations to be right.
My calculations are always right. As you know, young man.
Let's go.
Both very kind, but how am I supposed to get down that?
No problem. Just keep your cool, young man.
You filleting predicament for a scholar of my caliber, tied up like a sausage.
Or am I just nuts and bolts?
Think we'll find them. Yes, they don't leave their ship. Sun is getting closer. Oh
Nobody bothered to ask me how long this would take an oversight. No doubt. Okay. Okay. Forget it
This is hardly the time. I'm sure the mountain can't be too far away
We'll find someplace to shield us. Come on. Just a little further. Now what's wrong? I keep slipping
I wasn't built for this
Billy ate it. Oh, the truth is Peter. I don't know if I can make it. I can feel my strength going
I can't go on much longer.
Let's stop it.
If we stay here, it's sure death.
No, I won't let you.
What's wrong with her?
Psyche!
We get here.
How do you suppose?
Yours truly as usual.
You both seemed in need of physical assistance,
and I calculated that immediate shelter was the best of all solutions.
You feel better.
Yes, thanks, Metro.
We'll be okay now.
Did I sleep very long?
14 hours, 3 minutes, 10 seconds.
In two hours, we can set off again.
Meanwhile, save your strength.
Your share sure smells good.
When we get higher and farther to the south, it'll be even better.
It's too bright here. When we get over to the other slope, we'll check our position.
Okay, let's find another shelter before the sun returns. Let's go.
There's a path that leads right over to the other slope.
Why? When there's a perfectly good shelter right over there.
Look, it's great. What's wrong with this?
I mustn't kill him. I hated doing that.
It was him or me. You had to.
Realize that you just saved my life? What if he returns?
We'll keep an eye out. Don't forget, we're invading his territory.
It's not our job to kill him.
That's right, except in self-defense. And that's just what it was, Psyche.
Let's forget it and try to get some rest, right?
It has to be dark to make out the constellations.
How do you read it, Metro? Your programming puts you way ahead of us humans.
True, my memory banks classify 200 billion individual stars, and that's just in our own galaxy.
From the position of Almac, I calculate that there can be no error in concluding that we need not be altogether surprised to find ourselves on the planet Claris.
You're a handy fellow to have around.
I know.
Clarus, then welcome to an inhabited little planet.
Quite so. The Tolgs live here, not an awfully likable group.
Colonized four centuries ago by legions from Andromeda.
They're allies of ours. Let's go to the south and we'll be rescued.
Reluctant allies.
Maybe, but they are members of the confederation.
Come on, let's go.
Get your orders.
Meanwhile, nobody bothers to ask my considered opinion.
Look, water!
Out of hope of escaping.
No, I'm gonna save him.
No, Peter, don't. Don't kill anything.
It's their law in their jungle.
We'll ruin the ecosystem.
Yeah, but this is slaughter.
I've got an idea.
Big Baby is a plant eater.
He's mild as a lamb.
I think he's in love with you.
Guess what I'm thinking.
Pioneer in the frontiers of science tied to a prehistoric lump of ambulating protoblasm.
Some joke.
This situation is utterly ridiculous.
It's humiliating, and I hope it's all a bad dream.
Significance has ever happened.
I keep asking myself, what are we doing on this miserable planet in the first place?
Timbaltons!
I suppose you explain why you come to our world.
Why are you treating us like this?
We don't come as enemies.
It's not.
It is as spies as you come.
Not true.
You lie.
Trust the truth or else you shall die.
Don't shout at him.
You should help us.
Our ship crashed.
I swear that's the truth.
Very well.
Follow us.
Our leader Gabor will decide.
Not far now.
Around and admire the moonshell of our once great city.
Ah, well, just as I predicted, that explains everything.
This is the true sun we are circling.
And the red sun was circling around us.
and a collection of moons followed in their orbits, modified...
Look, forget it, okay?
...by a gravitation, of course, as you wish. I'm no blabbermouth.
Fortunately, you have chosen a bad time to visit us.
Why have you come? I want the truth.
We are members of the Omega Space Police, and our patrol ship crashed here, Gabor.
Space police, you say? Your ship here, you're spies.
No, I want the truth. I warn you, and I have ways of getting it.
...to make us see horrible things that aren't really there.
You're not impressed at all.
To have certain power.
Interesting.
We told you the truth.
We didn't come here as spies.
Our ship crashed here.
How innocent are your words.
Indeed, who would not believe you?
Well, too bad for you, but there's no time to check up on your story.
Tomorrow morning, two spies will be executed.
It will do wonders for one.
In such a hurry.
A fair question.
Tomorrow will be a big day.
The spaceships of our powerful friends are coming to deliver arms to us.
Cassiopeians, right?
Yes.
One more reason to kill you.
May as well know that with these arms, we will attack Europe, the improminent capital, and destroy it, as they have destroyed our city.
But for centuries now, your world has had peace and prosperity.
Yes, and slavery.
Henceforth, all power is only mine. I alone will rule my kingdom. Take them away.
We shall say goodbye in the morning.
We shall overcome.
Quickly.
Just fine. We mustn't judge my appearances.
All right, so I didn't make it this time.
But you'll see, we'll get out of this predicament.
What's this, the execution squad?
Look, see my glorious, courageous soldiers.
Traditional, I believe, to grant one last request.
Yeah, a good spacecraft.
I have one question.
You and your officers, you look totally different from your people.
Why is that? How come?
We are mixture.
A cross between these people and the Andromedan.
We are mutants, if you like.
Better to be superior among our own people than an underling among aliens.
Here was located the seat of our government.
Splendid spot for an execution.
Great.
It's time for us to take leave of each other.
You can tell them up there that all the customs were observed.
And now, to make the day perfect, here come our friends with weapons.
Go on! Shoot! They will not escape! Shoot them!
Figures nobody thinks of me.
Oh, we haven't forgotten you, Metro. You were great. We couldn't have made it without you.
We started monitoring your conversation when you came outside.
We had radio contact. We were waiting for the right moment to move in.
I don't mind telling you I was afraid we'd be too late.
It's a good thing that Metro's got reflexes like lightning.
Turning directly to our base, Colonel?
First, we'll go to Yurok and make a full report.
Putting their personal ambitions to one side, the fact that the rebels are armed by the Teryg should give us a lead on what to do.
Good thinking, son. And knowing we're here, the Cassipeans wouldn't dare come. Anyway, we're sure the Andromedans are on their guard.
Perhaps these people are sincere in their struggle.
Perhaps, but the Andromedans are members of the Confederation, our allies.
So what?